[Musique]
c'est un village isolé au milieu de la
forêt tropicale dans le nord de la
République démocratique du Congo au
milieu des maisons en terre l'église
saint-émil entre 1992 et 2001 un prêtre
slovénia officier son nom Joseph
surnommé José par les habitants pierre
Bobola l'a bien connue
de chœur le soir après la messe le Père
Joseph le fait régulièrement venir chez
lui
et il ouvrait la braguette de son
pantalon et il sortait son sexe il
commençait à se toucher à se masturber
au moment où il éjaculait je devais
tendre les mains reverser
ça la même dans la véranda là-bas
à moto le Père Joseph aurait selon
plusieurs victimes présumées agressées
des dizaines d'hommes à l'époque tous
mineurs certains évoquent aussi des
rapports avec pénétration Jean-Denis
avait 16 ans
[Musique]
des sommes d'argent pour qu'on ne dise
rien c'était des habits parfois du savon
il contribue aussi à mes études il
donnait de l'argent pour que je sois
scolarisé
comme Jean-Denis plusieurs jeunes
garçons ont pu étudier dans les villes
voisines de bandaka et picoro grâce au
soutien financier du Père Joseph au
village beaucoup d'anciens apprécient la
générosité du prêtre mais à l'époque les
abus ne sont pas connus
avec de l'argent pour leurs études les
jeunes les dépensent et se promener
partout dans le village avec Lui
Jésus ce qu'il s'était passé quand les
garçons ont commencé à parler mais avant
cela je n'avais rien vu
en 2001 deux victimes présumées
dénoncent le Père Joseph le prêtre est
inculpé par la police judiciaire de
pédophilie atteinte au mœurs et atteinte
à la sûreté de l'État auditionné il nie
toutes les accusations mais voici ce que
l'OPG conclut à la fin de son rapport
les allégations retenues à charge de
père José sont fondées dans la mesure où
il a des relations particulières avec
ces jeunes gens en dehors de la
communauté le Père Joseph n'a jamais
comparu devant un jugeant RDC selon cet
ancien prêtre la congrégation lazariste
en charge de la paroisse de moto donne
l'ordre de le faire rentrer le plus vite
possible en Europe les Provinciales est
venu mais solliciter si je pouvais faire
un mouvement vers moto et à les
rencontrer les confrères José pour que
trois heures du matin
je lui fasse
sortir jusqu'à beaubanda il n'a pas pu
traîner même à Kinshasa
évacué rapidement contactez la
congrégation affirme que le prêtre
n'était pas membre de l'Ordre est ni
tout lien avec le Père Joseph en 2021 le
père d'une des victimes présumées
relance l'affaire à sa demande la police
judiciaire congolaise auditionne
plusieurs victimes présumées et leurs
proches et elle conclut à nouveau que le
Père Joseph devrait être présenté devant
un juge 20 ans plus tard Claudine espère
encore obtenir justice pour son frère
décédé en 2014
nous avons fait cette déposition en 2021
parce que jusqu'ici personne ne nous a
aidé le prêt très très loin donc c'était
compliqué de faire les démarches depuis
ici dont mon témoignage je demande que
l'État fasse son travail dans cette
histoire on a perdu notre frère
l'année dernière 11 victimes présumées
se tourne aussi vers une ONG copine
internationale pour les représenter elle
transmet automatiquement leur témoignage
ainsi que ceux de plusieurs témoins
proches de victimes décédées
l'archidiocèse de bandakan n'a pas
souhaité nous accorder une interview
mais nous a fait parvenir à un
communiquer en août il révèle qu'une
enquête a été menée par l'archidiocèse
sous la supervision du dicaster pour la
Doctrine de la Foi la congrégation du
Vatican en charge des cannabis sexuels
commis par le clergé à la conclusion de
l'enquête après avoir évalué toutes les
preuves il a été considéré qu'il n'y a
pas d'éléments qui implique la
culpabilité de lacusé aucune autre
information sur l'enquête ne nous a été
transmise l’archid diocèse de bandaka
l'annonciature à Kinshasa et le dicaster
pour la Doctrine de la Foi n'ont pas
répondu à nos questions mais plusieurs
victimes présumées dont certaines
avaient écrit au Vatican nous ont dit ne
pas avoir été entendus par l'Église
c'est le cas de Michel qui préfère ne
pas donner son nom complet
[Musique]
de longues qui étaient un peu quand même
le témoin oculaire pour avoir de plus en
plus les informations mais personne l'a
fait pour les gens qui ont refusé que
non le monsieur il est dans le il est
pour rien j'aimerais même aussi
affronter ces gens-là je suis prêt je
suis vraiment prêt
internationale la gestion de cette
affaire démontre les failles de la lutte
contre les abus sexuels dans l'église
le fait que toutes les victimes n'est
pas été interrogées reflète la façon
dont les abus sexuels sur mineurs et
d'autres types d'abus sont traités à
travers le monde peu de pays en
particulier les pays en voie de
développement ont mis en place des
procédures de protection pour les
victimes
début 2022 un journaliste slovène novica
me iovic retrouvent la trace du Père
Joseph dans un article publié en Une du
journal des lots il révèle qu’une
plainte civile pour abus sexuel sur
mineur a été déposé par
l'épiscopatzlovène mais que les
poursuites ont été abandonnées car le
délai de prescription était dépassé
le Père Joseph officie aujourd'hui dans
la paroisse de Slive ça dans son pays
d'origine il a refusé de nous accorder
une interview des photos publiées sur
son compte Facebook et les réseaux
sociaux de la paroisse le montreposant
en compagnie d'enfants
l'archidocious de maryborde ont-ils
dépend déclare de son côté sans tenir au
résultat de l'enquête congolaise